[Music]
it's funny because you look so beautiful
tonight I see you always in the I wanna
see the tabloids but just in the press
in general you go to these big events
now you're a big star you went to the
Met Ball yeah in New York City which is
I think the most star-studded event they
took next to the Oscars maybe or maybe
even including the Oscars one of the
biggest events that you can be now for
sure invited to and did you have fun at
this thing I did it's like the they call
it like the Superbowl of fashion it's
very intimidating but he's great yeah I
know I had a great time and but you're
right there's like every possible
celebrity skinny celebrity yeah yeah and
the whole thing about the Met Ball is
you spend like three hours getting ready
and then you get your photo taken and
then you go in and like unstrap your
girl and eat your dinner but before you
go in you're like okay I got to make
sure this photo is great and you're just
randomly next to other celebrities oh
they just sort of pair you up with if
you if you don't go with the date they
just pair you up with someone yeah it's
such a fancy thing they don't give you a
date you guys like make a lot of friends
there they don't want like just a randos
there they don't even like like Rando
friends right so I'm so I was actually
right behind the musician common I'm
like a huge fan oh yeah and we actually
have a picture of you you guys are
standing next to each other so they they
got this
agree huh well you know it looks I saw
that picture and I thought you two were
together I mean that's what you just
think when you look at that picture
thank you Coenen thank you because after
that photo came out when we went up when
we parted ways and everything he was
right it's close we were on the carpet
and then a photographer was like ah take
a photo together
and he was like yeah whatever and I was
like oh yeah she's like handsome
oscar-winning common yeah yeah a person
that I would never be allowed to be five
feet away from we're not forced right
right and so I was like not agreeing I'm
just saying yes hey and so we we took
the photo I was like oh this is gonna be
great like the rumor mill starting of
like we're common and Mindy together or
why're they look at the sparks the
natural camaraderie they have they they
are in this picture they're hanging out
together it's clear they're an item yeah
yeah nothing no one like that story huh
nobody and I was just checking the whole
night ever it was everyone was like oh
Mindy so lucky that common took a photo
with her sick woman allowed to take
photo with
[Laughter]
well yeah you're saying you would like
it if there were rumors about you and
guys out there I think I've earned that
television for a long tour yeah I could
have parties where there's sometimes
good-looking people there just being
here people might think we're having a
three-way how I dress for my three-way
seven layers yeah exactly
you